[Music]
I'm just looking for who's asking John
chef jr. your son my son jr. yeah you
know they say that cash shed is a bad
mother shut up now
ignore him he's a black James Bond that
dude was real you think it was me
chapped yeah did you ever imagine in
your wildest dreams when you are a young
boy that you'd be playing a role like
this no I didn't like the thing that me
and my dad always talked about like in
terms of things that I want to do or
people that I want to work with and I
always mentioned like I can't believe
Samuel Jackson has done so many projects
and I haven't done anything with it and
he was I loved I mean what do you want
to do and I was I don't know I want to
do something that's real Sam like it
just feels like Samuel Jackson and when
chef came up I was like that's the
project I have to do this one and like I
was so happy that I actually like got
the role and like me and Sam really
meshed together and like Regina Hall is
in it too and I'm presenting an award
tonight all coming full circle
ladies syphilis madam chlamydia it's
lovely to meet you both it's doing you
well you look better walk back in the
day we didn't need guns all we needed
was our bare knuckle oh you can't be too
prepared role so how are we gonna bring
that unique spin to it you know Kenya
Kenya Barris wrote it so like that's the
unique spin right there I'm in good
hands you know he is like he brings
projects out like a little baby birds
and they just flutter and they blossom
into like big beautiful things and Tim
story directed it and Tim had an
incredible vision so the two of them
together kind of came up with this
concept that really captures what shaft
is and they sprinkled in just enough
like new touches to where people will
feel like it's a new version of
something that we're familiar with and
they can appreciate the old and the new
at the same time and I think you know I
think it's gonna be good
I laugh myself I'm sorry I laugh my
behind off we can't wait to see it I
love to hear that it's that nice balance
cuz you know how the trolls get so
right right right tell them to come for
me I'm ready for them on this one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]